in and of itself the curl is the most
fun thing ever I love the curl I love
the texture I love the feeling it's like
the snake in Qbert just hopping around
it's like a spring but the fact that
it's not available all the time makes it
even more special to me because when I
see it on the menu I'm like they got
curly fries awesome here's why the curly
fresh sucks okay you do get different
types and sizes and lengths of the curly
fry and what you end up with is two
things you end up with bits of curl that
are way overcooked love it crunchy dry
love it no uh you know overcooked and
then you end up with full curls that are
wet and mushy in the middle and crispy
on the ends now a crinkle cut fry is
there anything more fun is there
anything that takes you more back to
1985 drive-in movie theater the crinkle
fry if you had to make a character in a
cartoon that was a french fry you're
going with the crinkle fry it's
delicious because I think curly would be
in there too no I do